over a million people whose fixed rate
mortgage is due to run out before the
end of this year now the majority of
those fixed it below two percent and you
can't get much below five four percent
at the moment so for them I think
there's a real concern as well and we
found with our cost of living research
that people are paying 208 pounds more
now on their mortgages than they were a
year ago at that with all the other
costs we've seen Rising energy food Fuel
and it is a real squeeze for a lot of
households not just those on the lower
income we've actually found that people
who are earning a what you think of as a
comfortable income so between 40 and 80
000 pounds a year Well in some cases
although you know they've got more money
coming in but there's more money going
out and there are some signs of some
real squeezes there more likely to be
overdrawn at the end of the month more
likely to take out a payday loan more
likely to put money on their credit card
so I think there is some real real
course for concern not just for people
who are on on a tighter income who we
know spend more on food and fuel anyway
but actually those who we would normally
think of as as being reasonably
comfortable yeah so it's a real squeeze
for a lot of people absolutely Ros
Altman your former pensions minister so
talk us through what you think the
implications are of a higher interest
rate for people with pensions
well I think there is a an implication
for both pensions and for pensioners and
to some extent the latest if there is
going to be a rise in interest rates
which I personally think is not needed
but I understand there's pressure
internationally on the bank of England
to do it will make company pensions
um better funded and will also help
people who've got individual pension
pots to afford a higher lifetime pension
income in what's called an annuity but
if their money is invested
in bonds which were supposed to be very
low risk and give them a return related
to Market interest rates then there is a
risk that they will have lost money on
the Investments that they hold so it's
not always good news but as far as
pensioners are concerned the big issue
is to try and control inflation and that
actually is the crucial element for many
of them they're on fixed incomes if they
bought a lifetime income they didn't buy
inflation protection
oh
rates go up or not
they they actually need to be able to
afford to live on the basics which have
been going up so much in price apologies
for my exclamation there your line
dropped out briefly yeah sorry about
that Roz um your your line went black
just for two seconds but you came back
and we didn't miss we didn't miss the
meaning of what you said unfortunately
anyway so um I'll try and keep my
exclamations to myself though I don't
mean to put the guests off Michael let's
go back to you though because um Roz was
there talking about the pressures that
people are feeling because of this High
inflation that we've got at the moment I
mean 10.1 still in March and it is the
bank's job isn't it to keep inflation
under control the target is two percent
so it's way off that so why are these
consecutive interest rate Rises not
making as much of a dent as people would
like in that rate rise in that inflation
rate
well the main facts are overwhelmingly
which has pushed inflation up to these
very high levels over the last year and
a half has been the big rise in Energy
prices and global commodity prices and
that's pushed up prices for a wide range
of goods and services not just household
gas and electricity bills but Services
inflation Goods inflation and so forth
it takes a while for the Rises and
interest rates to Bear Down on inflation
remember the interest rates only started
to go up late 2021 really excited to go
up quickly from the middle of last year
the effects of those rapid rate Rises
will be coming through in the next few
Quarters at the same time the increases
in energy and other commodity prices
will be dropping out of the inflation
rates so we're now just about at the
turning point on inflation inflation's
set to fall really quite sharply in the
next few months by the end of this year
I think we'll be back down to about
three percent still a bit above Target
probably back down to two percent which
is the target next year well yes so
Sarah panels that will be of some
comfort to people potentially to know
that the rate of inflation isn't going
to carry on going up if all goes to plan
but that doesn't mean the price has come
down does it it just means they're not
going up as fast as they were absolutely
that's such a good point and it's you
know we hear that inflation is hopefully
coming down towards the end of this year
and as you say it sounds really
encouraging and of course it is because
it means prices aren't Rising as quickly
but we've all experienced it in the
shops especially because the food
inflation rate at the moment is almost
20 percent you know every time you go to
the supermarket the prices seem to have
risen and I think for a lot of people
you know again what we've been finding
is people have been making the easy
cutbacks already over the last year so
things like you know having for your
takeaways buying cheaper brands of food
buying less food going out less buying
fewer new clothes all those things but
there comes a point when actually that
doesn't help you anymore because you've
made all the cutbacks that you can or
the savings that you can make from those
cutbacks are actually quite minimal so
even if inflation starts falling and
Falls quite Sharp because of the high
prices that we're already paying
especially for things like food that you
know everybody needs food it's very hard
to cut back on that I think people will
find that their budgets are squeezed for
some time to come even if the news on
inflation is more positive
and resolvement and obviously every time
we talk about higher interest rates you
automatically think of the people who
are going to be badly affected and those
are the people with with mortgages as
we've been discussing with Sarah but
they're all Savers as well can they hope
to get better returns will the banks
follow suit after the bank of England if
it was to put sub-interest rates are
they likely to increase their savings
rates
well we can always hope but they're so
far has been a real reluctance
for by the big Banks to actually push
rates up in line with the way the base
rate has gone up Savers have been
shortchanged ever since rates started
Rising actually and of course they were
terribly damaged by the many years of
ultra low interest rates that we saw
before that so yes Savers can hope and I
would say that the banks do need to
reward Savers better the way that Rising
interest rates Works to control
inflation is supposed to be that it
dampens economic activity and stops
people spending that's the purpose in
many ways of pushing rates up so that
inflation isn't Under Pressure because
demand is weaker now if you encourage
people to save more and you reward those
who do save better
that might be a better way of actually
cooling the economy rather than
continually pushing rates up from what
are already
much higher levels than they were before
so you know you could encourage Banks to
reward Savers better they are being paid
well now with base rates for the money
that they deposit at the central bank so
that I think would be a more effective
policy than just pushing rates up which
of course has such negative effects as
you were describing on mortgage owners
and people who borrow
Michael what's your thought on that
so you know in the short term it sounds
great to have a system in which interest
rates for borrowers don't go up and
interest rates for Savers do go up
access sounds like we're all gaining
this as consumers
but the flip side of that obviously is
going to be a squeeze on banks profits
now that's okay for a bit but eventually
if you squeeze bank's profits too much
will we end up with banks which are weak
fragile and then what we've seen in the
past okay it's about 15 years ago we had
the banking crisis when the weakness in
the banking system contributed to a deep
recession multiple job losses widespread
company failures so it's important that
we have a solid and resilient Financial
system and unfortunately squeezing
bank's margins while it sounds like a
great thing
makes the financial system less
resilient in the long run
interesting okay and and Sarah panels a
quick thought about practicalities if
people do see the the bank put up the
base rate of interest the bank rate the
interest rate you call it lots of
different things at 12 o'clock are there
practical steps that people can take if
you're on a variable mortgage you will
see it increase would it be time to to
fix rates or is there a possibility that
from in the future we'll see rates
coming down again what kind of decision
can they make there I think it's quite
hard to predict if you've been hearing
interest rate Rises and and it doesn't
always feed through automatically into
things like fixed rate
amounts so it's quite hard to call that
in a way I think it does depend on your
personal circumstances such as your own
budget and your own capacity to have any
further Rises so it might be a time to
at least review your mortgage or have a
look of it look at it I would say don't
do anything in haste no knee-jerk
reactions and take advice from a
mortgage broker if you're not sure about
what to do because they'll know what's
happening across the market but the
other thing is if you have other
borrowing such as credit card borrowing
because this rate rise won't just affect
mortgages if you can overpay it so
you're paying down those those borrowing
those expensive borrowing that's
something to do because we are seeing
credit card rates Rising as well well
thank you to all three of you for for
teeing this up nicely this decision
which we will find out in the next few
seconds and we'll get your your thoughts
after we've heard that decision but let
me just bring in our business presenter
Ian King who joins us live from the city
and will talk us through the decision as
it comes in the next few moments so in
um the feeling is that the bank of
England will raise interest rates yeah
absolutely that's what the Market's been
pricing in we're expecting a rise from
four and a quarter percent to four and a
half percent uh 25 basis points in the
jargon really that has been nailed on
ever since the March inflation number
came in at 10.1 percent more than five
times the bank's Target rate of two
percent uh the big question I think is
the commentary that we get with the
statement today we've had in indications
from both the U.S federal reserve and
the European Central Bank over the last
week that they may pause on further
interest rate Rises and uh I'm just
hearing we have actually had the uh
number now
we have the number
yep we do the number is four point five
percent uh four and a half percent uh
Anna yes and the uh The crucial vote on
the monetary policy committee seven to
two uh there have been some speculation
that you might get a three-way split uh
the majority of members uh voting to
raise interest rates by a quarter of one
percent taking the back rate to four and
a half percent that is the highest rate
in this country since October 2008 very
much in line with what the market was
expecting there I suspect uh the two uh
people who voted against it uh when we
get uh that breakdown will have been
Swati dingra and uh sylvana tenrero they
of course are the uh Doves on the
monetary policy committee they already
think that uh interest rates have gone
uh sufficiently High I'm just uh trying
to have a look at the minutes now
um on the bank of England website uh the
manatee policy committee report has just
dropped of course we get a press
conference uh with Andrew Bailey the
governor at uh 12 30 our time
stuff about the coronation at the moment
uh says they're experiencing some
difficulties oh that's very interesting
we'll keep an eye on that and let me
just um tell viewers who are just
joining us then the bank of England has
raised the interest rate to 4.5 from
4.25 an increase of course of 0.25
following its latest monthly policy
committee meeting as Ian was saying that
takes it to its highest level since
October 2008 and it's the 12th
consecutive rise in the interest rate by
the bank of England so in obviously the
Hope here is to try to push down the
rate of inflation which has stayed so
stubbornly high yeah that's been the
real uh dilemma for the bank of England
inflation here in the UK remains higher
than in any other G7 country and in fact
the uh spread between UK inflation and
the rest of the G7 it is actually at a
40-year high the inflation remaining
very very sticky and impervious to all
attempts by the bank to uh to actually
bring it down with these 12 this is now
the 12th consecutive interest rate rise
that we've had from the bank the
previous ones do not appear thus far to
have had uh any impact in terms of
bringing down inflation as rapidly as it
has elsewhere in the developed world
that's to say inflation in the United
States we got the number there yesterday
4.9 percent
um and that is uh again that's something
that the bank of England would give its
eye teeth for
um just looking at uh some of the uh
commentary that we're getting now I mean
the the bank is actually indicating that
uh there may be further interest rate
Rises to come uh it's warning that
inflation is going to be higher this
year than it previously anticipated well
we actually already knew that because uh
inflation according to the bank's most
recent forecast in February uh was that
inflation in March would fall to 9.2
percent rather than the 10.1 it came in
at the bank is now forecasting inflation
is going to be around five percent at
the end of the year instead of the four
percent level that it was previously
forecasting that obviously has
implications for the Prime Minister
because uh he's uh made one of his five
campaign pledges to bring down inflation
very dramatically over the course of the
year uh the bank has also upgraded its
growth forecasts for the UK economy very
interestingly uh that is in common with
uh what a number of other forecasting
bodies around the world have been doing
uh in fact uh this is the biggest
upgrade to a growth forecast now in the
history of the monetary policy committee
and another key headline coming out of
the minutes here is that the monetary
policy committee now no longer expects
there to be a recession this year that
is a dramatic turnaround in events you
if if you think back to the Autumn of
last year the bank was uh predicting a
recession not only for the whole of 2020
23 but in going into the first quarter
of 2024 the bank now no longer expects
there to be a recession uh in the UK
this year and again that is pretty
significant I think that points to the
resilience that we've seen in the UK
economy over the last uh few months uh
certainly since the beginning of the
year the gep numbers have come in
routinely higher than the bank had been
forecasting and so that is no real
surprise there to see the bank upgrading
its forecast for us I say that is a
pretty dramatic indication the bank's
minutes also indicating that uh food
prices in particular have come as a
surprise uh to the banker they're rather
stronger than anticipated by the bank
and of course the key issue here the
reason the thing that's really spooked
the bank of England is the fact that uh
core inflation which is the measure of
inflation that strips out volatile
elements such as energy food drink
alcohol and tobacco well that has been
far far stickier but much slower to come
down the bank was anticipating that
points to what economists call second
round effects in the economy in other
words the inflation that we're now
seeing in the system is domestically
generated rather than being due to
external factors such as the war in
Ukraine which of course sent Energy
prices spiking last year and also pushed
up the price of a lot of agricultural
Commodities as well so the bank clearly
concerned still about core inflation and
certainly very very concerned about core
inflation in particular
okay Ian thanks very much indeed and Ian
I'm told the bank of England website is
up and running again so go and have a
delve in there and in the meantime I
want to bring in our economics and data
editor Ed Conway who's at the bank of
England for us now so Ed as expected the
bank of England putting the interest
rate up by a quarter of one percent and
interesting what else they've had to say
about the economy
yes it's the 12th successive increase uh
in interest rates from the bank of
England we've never seen quite such a
kind of successive set of increases as
since the bank was made independent in
1997 but this is also partly you get
what their their decision is on interest
rates but you also get a sense of what
they think is going on with the economy
because they also every quarter
announced what is known as their
monetary policy report they look at the
state of the economy and say well how's
it doing so we're also getting a sense
of just how they think things are
looking and here you know there is
actually some quite good news they talk
about upgrading their growth forecasts
by the biggest amount that they have
ever done in the history of the monetary
policy committee now it's worth just
saying they were pretty miserable
beforehand they were talking about the
longest recession that we'd seen in
modern history now they're talking about
what might be considered to be kind of
more or less flatlining growth so
marginally positive they're not
expecting to see any contraction this
year and that's basically what a
recession is when the economy is
shrinking so that's good news the kind
of thing to note is it's not bringing us
into kind of the feel-good factor we're
not going to see growth that is anything
like what it has been in previous booms
they're talking about growth of below
one percent both this year next year and
the year after so it's not necessarily
something to celebrate except it's not
as bad as it
and at the same time they're talking
about inflation being slightly higher
than previously expected and that higher
inflation means there is slightly more
pressure on the bank of England to act
when the bank is doing what it's doing
it's trying to kind of raise interest
rates change interest rates to try and
bring inflation more under control and
inflation is considerably higher than it
previously thought you'll have seen
recently inflation's still above 10 well
it does expect it to get down to around
five percent by the end of the year as
Ian was saying just a moment ago the
Prime Minister does have that Target
doesn't he to try to halve inflation by
the end of this year this according to
the bank means he might just about make
it looking at their kind of what's
coming out of their models he should
just make it but it's going to be much
much tighter than previously expected I
think the final thing to note is that
you know we are living at the moment
through a cost of living crisis the
likes of which we really haven't seen in
living memory and what the bank is kind
of contributing to that is partly is
trying to bring down inflation but in
order to do that it is Raising interest
rates so now up to 4.5 percent those
interest rates take quite a while to
filter through into our pockets and you
know if you have a mortgage you're it
it's up to when you're refixing that
mortgage that you're going to start to
feel that pain and according to the bank
of England only about a third of that so
they put rates up it takes a while
before those households around the
country need to raise to refix their
mortgages and obviously suddenly go up
from maybe it was kind of one percent up
to four percent or even higher that's
taking a while to come through and only
according to the bank only about a third
of the pain from those Rising interest
rates has yet been felt so there is
still a lot of pain two-thirds of that
pain yet to come so there is a bit of
you know it's not necessarily going to
make this The Filling of the cost of
living crisis go away for many families
particularly around the country
particularly those who don't necessarily
have the savings built up from the
pandemic particularly those who are on
mortgages at the moment it's going to be
quite tough over the course of the next
few months but the bank does say the big
picture for the economy is considerably
less bad than it was before they're not
talking about recession they're very
happy that energy prices aren't quite as
high as they were previously and they
say that things certainly don't look as
bad as they were last time they looked
at the numbers so that is at least
something to take solace in
well yes so some positives there aired
but as you say the interest rate has
been raised have they given any hints
about whether that's the last one
well every time the bank raises interest
rates they obviously they announce the
decision you get kind of the the
determination about how many people on
the monetary policy committee because
it's essentially in that building there
is a policy Committee of nine people
that meets to decide these things this
time around it was a 7-2 vote so they
vote on it and we get the minutes and
then alongside the minutes you get a few
paragraphs that kind of provide a little
bit of a hint about what they might do
in future and in this case I suppose the
main point is that those paragraphs were
kind of the same as they were before and
previously they were saying basically if
things kind of carry on as we expect
them to carry on then we probably
shouldn't need to raise rates further
than the market current expects and the
market currently expects rates to go up
one more time so what we could be
looking at right now is we're very close
to the peak it could well be that
there's an extra increase but of course
you never know and it's worth just
bearing in mind that one of the things
that the bank has talked about today is
the fact that it's been taken uh by
surprise taken aback by how fast food
inflation is going up at the moment they
just didn't expect food prices to go up
so high and we all know again we are
paying those prices we're seeing that in
the supermarket every day well the man's
looking at them and saying oh well maybe
they are going up a bit higher than we
expected a bit faster than we expected
and they might be going up a bit faster
next year as well so all of those things
would actually all EL secret put a bit
more pressure on the bank to raise
interest rates but as I say most people
in the markets think maybe one more
increase so you're getting to 4.75
the thing to note though okay is that
that might sound low in historic
comparison okay look back through
history and there were periods where
interest rates were up at like 10 double
digits even above that however in those
periods the level of debt that many
people had around the economy mortgage
people but those who had mortgages and
so on was smaller than it was it was
smaller than it is now so higher debt
the fact that we are slightly less able
less equipped with higher incomes to be
able to pay that debt means the squeeze
that you face from everyone's full
increase in interest rates is much
greater now than it was before so even
though it's four percent even though
it's 4.25 even though it's four and a
half percent as it has just gone up to
today that still has a bearing on many
households and what they're paying for
their mortgages that is similar to what
you saw in the 1980s and getting up
towards the 1990s so this is still the
important stuff and it's still it's
still very painful for many households
indeed
it will indeed and we'll be talking to
many people affected throughout the day
of course but Ed thanks very much indeed
for all those latest lines from the bank
of England and your analysis of them and
in fact we've had reaction just in the
last few moments from Labor's Shadow
Chancellor Rachel Reeves responding to
that rise in the base rate of interest
she has said we're a brilliant country
with so much to offer but families and
businesses across Britain will be
spending today racked with anxiety by
another interest rate rise uh Rachel
Reese goes on to say the Prime Minister
should take his fingers out of his ears
and admit responsibility for a Tory
mortgage crisis leaving so many worse
off she goes on he trapped our economy
in a cycle of low growth and high taxes
while tickling the tummies of unfunded
trickle-down tax extremists in his party
Liz truss simply came and lit the fuse
and finally she goes on to say a labor
will build a stronger economy and get it
growing so that's a labor Shadow
Chancellor responding to the bank of
England's decision to raise the base
rate of interest by a quarter of one
percent this lunch time well let's
return to our panel to get a reaction to
the bank's decision with me this
lunchtime our former pensions Minister
baroness Ross Altman Michael Saunders
senior advisor at Oxford economics and
former bank of England monetary policy
Committee Member and with me here
Consumer Finance specialist at Royal
London Sarah Pennell so welcome back to
all of you thanks for your patience
there Michael Saunders I'm going to come
to you first of all we got the decision
that you predicted that a lot of people
had predicted a quarter point rise in
the bank rate
um so no surprise there was it the right
move in your in your view
oh yes it was um the recent rates
inflation has been too high for comfort
and higher than the bank of England had
expected previously as I said earlier a
rate rise today was a nailed uncertainty
looking up to their forecasts and their
commentary though I think the bank's
message is that although the economic
Outlook is not as bad as they thought
the economy is still pretty flat so
that's not going to be a great picture
for growth and if interest rates follow
the market path which is for one or two
more hikes then inflation in their
Central forecast ends up below Target
two and three years out so the message
from that is really that interest rates
maybe they'll go up a little bit more
but they're probably near the peak
okay and Sarah panels what should people
watching make of this are they going to
be better or worse off I mean obviously
it'll depend on what kind of mortgage
they have or whether they're Savers with
no mortgage but what's your reaction to
what you've heard about how people will
feel I think a lot of people will feel
very anxious so we know that concerns
about mortgage costs has doubled in the
last six months that's what our research
showed and and I think if this interest
rate came in isolation that would be one
thing but as we were hearing from from
Ed earlier on and from panel members
because we know obviously all the other
costs have been rising and Rising so
sharply I think there is is real concern
and I think the next thing to look out
for is what the energy rate regulator of
gem says about the energy price cap now
that's going to give its announcement at
the end of May the end of this month and
that will tell us how much we'll be
paying for our energy bills from July
because as we know sort of the energy
price guarantee the government's help
was extended but from the summer unless
things change whereas many of us are
going to be sort of on our own now
hopefully we won't be using much energy
over the over the summer months but we
do know that concern really starts
building once we hit sort of organ
September so I think for a lot of people
for those certainly you have variable or
tracker rate mortgages but also those
whose fixed rate mortgage is due to end
within the next six nine months will
definitely be concerned but those two
who have borrowing apart from say things
like a bank loan which is fixed as I
said I think a lot of people have been
making All the Right Moves In terms of
cutting down on their day-to-day
spending I think again one slight area
of concern is we've seen people really
running down their savings now in a way
if you have savings the whole point is
they're there for an emergency they are
that cushion for the rainy day and we've
had plenty of those recently but we
found that people have been making some
quite serious inroads into their savings
and in fact one in five people told us
they've got less than a hundred pounds
in savings now that's a real cause for
concern because if your if your income
isn't rising in line with interest rate
Rises and inflation which most people's
isn't and you don't have savings you can
call on then we know people are going to
end up feeling very squeezed and for
some of them they will feel like they're
pushed into taking on borrowing which
when it comes to to Everyday spending is
rarely the answer so I think there is
some real concern there okay yes so a
mixed picture but generally very tough
for people a resultment former pensions
minister of course what does this mean
for pensioners do you think
well I I think it is of concern for
pensioners significantly it's hard to
see how a quarter point interest rate
increase is going to make much
difference to inflation which is caused
by the significant rise in food prices
and in energy costs and other basic
materials and pensioners are going to
end up cutting
cutting back but they can't cut back on
food and energy without causing real
damage to themselves if they were trying
to live on the savings and the rate
Rises aren't being passed on in full
which they clearly are not being
then again their income is not going to
be going up they're not working they
can't earn more they can't do anything
really to protect themselves that's a
real problem but in the end of course
for borrowers this is a significant
problem and one of the big issues for
the economy and inflation has been that
there has been so much extra debt taken
on and Rising interest rates sort of
makes that worse in many ways so it's
not clear to me that although the bank
of England feels it must do something
and the only something it sees is
interest rates that what it has done is
going to be the defining factor and I
worry about the negative impacts that
the interest rate rise will cause
especially if the feed through
mechanisms are blocked you know some
mortgage holders can extend their
mortgage some will stay on fixed rates
they will be relatively okay for a while
but underlying playing the real concern
is that the level of inflation is not
something that will respond to ongoing
interest rate increases unless you cause
a massive downturn or weakness in the
economy we're talking about stagflation
at the moment but if you had a real
downturn then you might end up seeing
that the bank of England has to start
lowering rates and printing more money
which would be pretty ironic we're in a
we're in a vicious circle perhaps I
think I hope that the bank of England
will not increase interest rates anymore
from here and that we will look for
other policy measures okay that will
help to control inflation from now on
okay and and Michael Saunders just a
reflection on the upgrading of the
bank's growth forecast obviously there's
there's lots of people to be concerned
about here but is that reason for
optimism that they're talking about
upgrading the growth forecast by the
biggest amounts that they ever have but
it is from a pretty low base isn't it
yeah she has to remember that their
previous forecast was extremely bleak a
long and deep recession that their
previous forecast was in the context of
very high energy prices last Autumn and
uncertainty about the extent of
government fiscal support so since then
wholesale Energy prices have come down a
long way and of course the government
gave households a lot of Support over
the winter and so that whole energy
squeeze on incomes although it's been
severe has not been as bad as feared I
have to say stagflation describes how
the economy has been
but looking forward inflation is set to
fall really quite sharply we're not
going to get strong growth in real wages
but we are now increasingly High
inflation is going to be a story of the
rear mirror rather than the
forward-looking story and that's got to
be good news for consumers hasn't it
amid all these worries Sarah the fact
that inflation rates at least will come
down yes as you say I think there is
some optimism looking forward and I
think it is one other thing to say which
is that I think a lot of people do feel
very worried understandably about what's
happening at the moment but we know that
some people don't ask for help that's
available and for understandable reasons
I mean there's some research out a
couple weekends ago saying that 19
billion pounds is unclaimed in state
benefits so I think if there's one
message that I would like people to take
away it's do ask for help you know don't
suffer in silence if you are struggling
if you are worried about your mortgage
talk to your mortgage lender or mortgage
broker you know there are debt advice
Charities if you need that help and and
there is there's there's sort of State
benefits that may be available for
people and indeed you know for pensions
on a low income there's there's benefits
available to them and there's one of the
most unclaimed benefits so I'm not
saying there's help for everybody
everybody I'm not I'm not saying that
but there may be help for you that you
just aren't aware of so I would say
there's one thing and you are worried do
reach out for help well yes and if you
do have a mortgage and you have a
Tracker and your your interest rates
will go up automatically is there
anything that people in that situation
can do can they get a holiday from their
mortgage for a bit if they're really
struggling yeah so when we had the
covert pandemic the financial regulator
kind of moved it with all the mortgage
lenders and the financial services
industry and put in place a number of
measures now so mortgage lenders are
kind of very Adept at understanding you
know the kind of things that people
might need and we do know that a lot of
people are financially struggling so it
may be the case that it's a payment
break or payment holiday or it may be as
was referred to earlier on actually
extending the term of your mortgage and
I think a lot of people feel very
nervous about that because thinking why
why would I want to have my mortgage for
longer but just because your your term
is extended doesn't mean you have to
have your mortgage for that long so if
your situation improves or mortgage
rates become more affordable you may be
able to overpay and then reduce your
turn back down again so sometimes I
think measures so people maybe feel a
bit worried thinking well I don't want
that because I don't want to be tied
into my debt for longer but it could
just give you that temporary breather
that gets you back on track and then
once your situation improves or interest
rate Falls interest rates fall then you
can actually get back to the situation
you wanted to be in so I said there are
things and there are measures that you
may not be aware of so I said whether
it's talking to your own your the
company that you owe money to whether
that's your credit card provider your
mortgage borrower or indeed to a debt
advice charity or there's an
organization called money helper there
may be help available that you're just
not aware of okay better to communicate
and absolutely there may be some options
for you yeah and Russell what about
those who are watching who are thinking
of retiring soon
you know what would your advice be to
those people I mean is there a clear
picture out there or is it quite a
tricky decision
well I think you need urgently to look
at how much money you have got your
pension fund may have fallen in value or
it may indeed have have increased you
need to work out what income you might
get the best advice you can give I think
is that if you don't absolutely need to
retire and you can keep working even
part-time that is likely to see you
through a period of economic crisis and
cost of living troubles better than if
you say oh well I'm just going to give
up now
and also of course speak to your pension
provider and understand what they can
offer you keep invested for longer if if
rates are at or near their Peak then
that should underpin markets quite
nicely if rates keep going up then if
you've got a lot of money in the bond
markets you might want to move some of
that but make sure that you make a plan
and understand what you've got check you
know so many people have got pensions
that they've forgotten about or don't
know about make sure that that you know
how much you're on track for and also
speak to employer if if you are still
employed about maybe working less hours
but still having earnings coming in
because that again can really help tide
you over unless you're in very poor
health in which case as Sarah says look
at what benefits would be available to
you as well to help you through what
hopefully will be a difficult year but
then hopefully a better year coming the
following year and thereafter
and Michael a thought as well for those
in employment looking at the projected
inflation rate because a lot has been
said in disputes between the government
and and unions and workers who feel that
their wages aren't keeping up with
inflation that's caused a great deal of
unrest and we've seen a lot of strikes
because of it what are the implications
of inflation coming down on wages and
and how inflationary are they something
the government's long been arguing
so the rise in inflation that we've had
is really not due to higher wages it's
been due to Energy prices and real wages
are for them I'd say company profits
have fallen as well it hasn't overall
been a story of company profiteering
margins have been squeezed quite
markedly so these banking forecasts show
inflation falling quite a lot over the
course of this year I have to say I
think there's a chance inflation might
even fall a bit faster than they expect
given the decline in global commodity
prices and size that the labor market is
easing here
an interesting one to watch and and
Michael we have got a news conference
due to start shortly by the governor of
the bank of England Andrew Bailey
um what would you expect from that I
mean they lay out their forecast don't
they and they get questions from the
journalists what are you looking out for
so I think it'll be important to see
what he says about the outlook for
interest rates and how he positions the
bank of England compared to the U.S
Central Bank who said they're pausing
and the and the European Central Bank
who said they're expected to hike
further I suspect he will be perhaps not
as set on higher interest rates as the
European Central Bank but equally not as
committed to reports as the Fed so a
willingness a willingness to hike grades
a bit further if needed but not
um not as dogmatically set on as the
European Central Bank seems to be well
yes and let's just show you the scene
there at the bank of England there's the
scene where we will see the governor of
the bank of England Andrew Bailey walk
in and hold that news conference are
flanked by his advisors as well and
Sarah panels um what should people at
home be watching out for in this what's
the most crucial thing that could affect
the most people that we could hear from
the from the governor
really is about the sort of future
direction of interest rates and also
expectations for inflation because I
think those are really the the big twin
pressures as we've been hearing and
obviously we've had a big change in
interest rates since they started rising
in December 2021 and if you think back a
year ago interest rates were just one
percent so there's been quite a dramatic
change in that time but if we are
nearing the peak
um or if we're going to have sort of one
more rise that's definitely something to
watch out for